what's up you guys it's jay mendoza and
his nameless james and uh where are we
we're in sunnyside california in la at
dodger stadium it's 20 22 home run derby
what are we doing well we're competing
for home run balls me versus him and i
can tell you
i have no concerns about who's going to
win this they say talk is cheap you know
what i'm saying again not concerned
who's going to get this w let's go let's
go
uh i actually have no idea where we're
going though are we in the left pivot or
right pavilion let's just go into the
bleachers come on
wow
see mr field everybody who comes up to
me i'm going to tell them you got to
help me hey we need your help though how
many do we catch them
all of them
so if you catch all of them just give me
one
i'll give you a half i got to catch as
many balls as i can all right all right
she's going bare hands
give her the clothes
on three one two three
what it seems is gonna benefit me is
talking to the people that recognize all
right let's take this picture so we're
hopefully with jack nobody recognizes
him so winners on three
one two three winners hey right here
baby i know you get the heck out of here
i want feedback on my thought process
i'm thinking everyone's crowding here so
i feel like a lot of balls are going to
be hit here i feel like if you stand
back here
you have more
room to move around that's right you
know if any any little ricochets you can
get them can i come down there
oh wait bro this mic just this cam just
fell
might have misplaced my 360 cam so we
just got the word that jack lost his 360
camera
he's already losing his game i feel like
i got a stretch dude we got to stretch
we got we got to run for some balls got
to be fast bro
i'm warming up i'm warming up all right
we're going to get a ball right we're
going to get one right here
thirty time baby
[Applause]
you wanna see some home run
[Applause]
we were right though we were right man
the chances are here one of them
he got a ball you want to sell it come
on what are we doing let's sell it come
on
let's see what these guys are doing is
queer seeker a lefty do you guys know
who's up next a seeker hey right bill
let him go
hey that was a lot of balls to get
caught over there but empty i don't know
where to go right here got to go in
there
come on speaker i'm a dodger fan come on
i'm not doing that
hey you want to see all that real quick
no oh damn as you guys can see
through
i need help jay's not quick enough
not like this
this is way harder than i thought if
you're in the crowd with people like
even if it's right to you you gotta
battle for those whereas if you're in a
general vicinity just around them you
can react better right
here we go here we go
i ain't a pretty good spot to be
[Applause]
now
guys
all right we gotta try to get a ball
right now we're gonna get one all right
get this guy out here and my dad's in
the home run he has like three balls
already tell him to give me one so i can
win i don't care what happens he's not
getting a ball i will tackle him to the
ground and rip it out of his net hey go
chase some balls bro
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
he's got four on the board i don't know
if we stay here if we move this is so
much harder than i thought it was gonna
be i wonder if i could go down there
with the credentials so if we could try
to get down there all right so here's
what we're gonna do we've been trying
we're gonna refuel get some water maybe
a little snack everyone's saying i gotta
try to dodge your dog
we got one step closer so if you want it
if you want more
and that's where he's getting
okay
okay i don't know should i get a dodgy
dog like i feel like i have to um i
think i might do a dodger dog
[Music]
hey do you want to sell that to me
how much you want i'll send you 350
right now
oh so you already caught one
batting practice oh
i got my ball thank you thanks all right
let's find some condiments oh what is
this
a lot damn that was so good
[Applause]
i thought i was gonna hit you i got you
i got you i got you explicit camera
equipment here look at this look at this
watch out
oh
[Applause]
i can't believe i caught the
ball about
hold on let me call my wife
i got them all
i got a bomb
jack i'm sorry too lost bro this is
tough i just gotta like throw throw my
glove out there all these people
catching balls
[Applause]
no way no way how are you feeling right
now by the way pretty great amazing you
got two you want to go to the podcast
getting real real down motivation morale
is whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
what a day
what a day i wonder what jay's up to
probably paying people to give him balls
like a poser i'll give him here i'll
give him the champ is here game out on
time hey
i'm happy that jay went at home that's
derby it was great effort great effort i
don't know to start
paying people
did i lose my money
[Music]